the baros is a big league streamer
that's become famous in recent years for
his unique play style and when I say
unique I mean he dies a lot in his games
but he usually still wins last week
though he was banned for intentionally
feeding this has sparked a big debate in
the community about whether or not he
deserved the ban and what we actually
mean when we say intentionally feeding
okay whether you're new here or you've
just forgotten to do it yet I highly
recommend you subscribe to the channel
if you haven't done so already we're now
over 2 million we're on the road to 3
million subscribers you can be one of
the first people on that road yeah do it
subscribe and like the video if you
enjoy it okay so last year we made a
whole video specifically about the bios
for our offbeat series it details how
the Swedish streamer has become famous
in recent years for his unique strategy
with his main Champion Scion if you tune
into his stream often you'll be used to
seeing him die over and over again but
somehow generally speaking he'll pull
out wins more often than losses
essentially up to a point his deaths
don't really matter but not everyone was
happy when he first arrived on the scene
a few years ago a few voices in the
community thought this was nothing more
than glorified hinting streamers who
played with him accused him of ruining
their games and lower ranked players
blamed him for the copycats who died as
much as him but failed to actually win
and in January 2021 it seemed Ryan
agreed with them when they banned him
for intentionally feeding later that
year the vowels told me that he
suspected the ban came after a handful
of High ELO players had targeted him
basically
in Halo there are a lot of people that
are not very liked
you know I think I'm one of them like if
there are many people that this dislike
this dislike me Trader I wouldn't be
surprised if the if if there are people
that report me every single game even if
I play well
just because they dislike me he was
eventually unbanned and bounced back for
the last two years he's been able to
avoid riots banhammer until last week
the Thursday stream had started fairly
normally for him he won a few lost a few
but his sixth game of the day was the
start of a four-game losing streak on
Scion the next game he switched things
up and went for illawi but things went
from bad to worse as he lost the game
with a high-watering 218 scoreline
ah this is so bad I [__] up
and the game after that didn't go much
better this Quinn game saw him die 18
times once again but little did the
barrels know that the enemy Nunu a
streamer called Kesha had announced to
his stream early in the game that he
wanted to Camp the bounce for his
teammate the stream of spear shots tax
he's doing it on purpose isn't he guys
he they have four sweepers
what are they stop ganking balls guys
we're gonna see the bars 10 times in
laning face okay ten times in laning
face shot spear shop it's a spare shot
I feel so bad from like what is that
what like what's the counter play chat
and his waves so
I'm sorry boss and after the boss's
first 11 deaths Kesha wasn't shy at all
about his intentions
let's destroy him let's destroy him
we're gonna get him banned we're gonna
get the boss banned and well he got his
wish as soon as the game was over the
boss was hit with a two-week suspension
that is just so [__] annoying
give me man what the [__]
no
what why leave him alone just let him
play the game
when he announced the ban on Twitter
even his friend kadral couldn't help but
point out the absolute red carpet the
boss had laid out for himself that day
those last six games saw him rack up 20
kills 22 assists and 68 deaths in fact
45 of those deaths came in just the last
three games where he averaged over 15
deaths a game it seems like that last
game was the final nail in the coffin I
imagine by this point he racked up
enough reports to trigger Ryan's
automatic detection system the question
is did he deserve this ban some people
felt that the bounce had simply been the
victim of an enemy jungler whose only
intention was to ruin his game While
others were quick to point out that this
is literally the system working as
intended even some of his fans felt like
the reports he got were somewhat
Justified I think there's a couple of
issues at play here firstly where do you
draw the line between just dying a lot
and intentionally feeding nobody would
argue that dying loads but still trying
your hardest in a game game is a
punishable offense
okay maybe some people would but what
the mouse was banned for was
intentionally feeding I feel like that
phrase is so overused that we sometimes
forget its original meaning
intentionally feeding kills to the enemy
now his critics May disagree but I don't
think you can watch those final games
and tell me there was intent behind
those deaths is it horrible for his
teammates to deal with absolutely should
they just have to put up with it no but
was the bow still trying to win those
games I'd say yes would people be having
this conversation about him if he died
all of those times but had won a few of
those games the match results may be
different but the intent is still
exactly the same no matter how many
times the boss dies there's clearly a
difference between his games last week
and for example what Tyler Warren used
to do back in the day where he literally
announced he was going to run it down
and then he'd do just that but despite
us clearly seeing a distinction there we
still call both of those things
intentionally feeding I'd be interested
to hear your thoughts when the mouse was
first banned for this two years ago game
play designer director Mark yetter
seemed to acknowledge it was a false
positive that would be fixed by the
player support team upon review perhaps
a similar thing will happen this time
but it's already been almost a week now
and there's been no sign of the Bowser's
return is that a sign that Riot does see
this as intentionally feeding on
yesterday's Nemesis stream bow seemed in
good spirits when explaining why he
wouldn't be joining Champions Q the main
reason why these Pro players go to
Champions Q is so they can avoid people
like me like that they even want to play
that
I know I know will the bounce have
anything to say about this when he
returns to his stream next week and for
that matter does Roy have anything to
say he's one of the game's biggest
streamers and if this happens again
it'll be something they can't ignore
is it horrible for his teammates to have
is it horrible me horrible for his
teammates
is it horrible for his teammates to deal
with absolutely should they just have to
put up with it and shut up no
but why is this so hard